la gestion de la crise sanitaire à
l'école par votre ministre de
l'éducation nationale au cours de la
semaine passée a été un fiasco complet
que dire de la méthode quand le premier
protocole sanitaire a été présenté sur
un média payant à 17 heures la veille de
la rentrée
que dire encore de ce protocole
totalement ubuesque est intenable les
parents s'arrachent les cheveux combien
ont dû quitter leur travail
précipitamment pour récupérer leurs
enfants et le faire tester combien ont
dû se lancer dans le parcours du
combattant allant de pharmacie en
pharmacie lesquels sont débordés pour
tenter de respecter vos préconisations
les écoliers mes chers collègues sont
traumatisés par ces tests répétés les
conséquences scolaires et psychique
seront considérables que dire des
multiples revirements de votre
gouvernement depuis la rentrée un
premier protocole a été remplacé par un
deuxième puits par un troisième tout le
monde est complètement perdue alors
monsieur le premier ministre quand
allez-vous en finir avec cette
improvisation permanente qui décourage
professeurs parents élèves quand
allez-vous anticiper les conséquences de
vos décisions avant de les imposer aux
français dans la précipitation